- So in your book, you
talk about what happened
to you at the Super Bowl.
Can you tell that story?
'Cause I mean,
I have had to do that at
the Super Bowl as well
and it is already nerve-wracking.
Can you tell everybody what happened?
- Yeah, what year was it?
It was 199- I think it was
six, I think it was 199-
No, 1995.
Super Bowl 29.
And I was asked to sing
the National Anthem
which is a huge honor.
And yet at the same time it's terrifying.
There are, I mean that goes world wide
and you don't even wanna,
Barry Manilow had said to
me right before I did it,
he did it the year before and
Barry's been a great friend
through all these years.
And he said, Kathy no matter what you do,
do not look up at the scoreboard
and look at how many people
are gonna be watching.
Don't do it.
- Oh good Lord, don't tell her that.
(laughs)
- Yeah, well I'll tell you the story.
It was, we have something called
Final Looks in our business
which is, we're ready to go,
hair makeup get over there,
do whatever final touches you're gonna do
'cause it's go, we're ready.
And so my hairdresser, by mistake,
does hair spray on me
and goes in my right eye.
Boom, right in my right eye and
I'm going blinded from that.
And then my makeup artist is working on me
one the other side and she has a-
- [Kelly] A wand.
- A mascara wand, boom,
right into my left eye.
So I'm walking out like,
they had to lead me.
They don't wait for you at the Super Bowl.
So they're leading me out and
I can hear everybody scream
and I can hear all this noise
and I'm going, oh Jesus,
help me Jesus, help me.
I get there and then of course
the orchestration starts.
You can hear the
orchestra, full orchestra.
And it's time for me to sing,
of all the lyrics, "Oh say can you" what?
See.
(audience laughs)
And I'm going, no, I can't see,
(laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's awesome.